[Music]
how many times do you think there's a
healthy amount of times to watch one
movie
one movie
you mean like watching it over and over
dude i [ __ ] go through movies like i
did with women
what does that mean
you return them on time they ate your
[ __ ] they get away with they get away
from me oh i see no no i just watch and
i don't watch it again i i just can't
bear with it
when i was a kid and you know it's
different because you had to rent a
movie and you only had five days from
blockbuster hollywood video and i rented
best of the best dude fire bro and i
watched it 11 times in a row holy philip
came in the tight american taekwondo
team to filibri yeah and he competes
against the korean yeah it's just a
taekwondo martial arts movie where u.s
goes against [ __ ] korean anytime so
you watch it 11 in a row 11 in a row
because i had to return it remember how
hollywood video also had two day rentals
that was a two day rental for some
[ __ ] reason wow
dude was it a tape or dvd because you
give you give it some [ __ ] wear
though you you actually watch you can
watch a movie and then you're done
you're like you know what play that back
you could do that what was your favorite
scene in that movie dude when he's like
alexander greedy
i know everything about
you yeah
that was very good how come everyone
back then had a japanese accent too the
chinese the koreans everybody got a
japanese master splinter dude man
everybody it's good it's really good
how come you can't watch a movie over
and over
dude cause i think that's actually the
the
not the norm because i could do that for
music if there's a hit there's like man
let's play that back you know but if
it's a movie that's like
i don't know that's like eating
leftovers i mean leftovers are bombing
[ __ ] in a different situation he's got a
kid so he's watching [ __ ] every movie
but i didn't even watch movies though so
it's not even fair but like for example
like um when i first watched inception
the minute i walked out i bought another
ticket to watch another addiction yeah i
was a damn that was really good the only
time i did that was for borat
so it shows the depth between yeah the
depth the depth okay interesting
interesting i did that [ __ ] football oh
you bought a ticket instantly the second
time that's the only movie i've watched
like within a week span to pay for it
was [ __ ] good yeah i watched the same
session like i didn't go home it was you
know the same the same day i walked out
i bought the next show and watching this
town center yeah like 10 20 minutes
right after i still in the 2010s
inception was the best movie that decade
yeah it was next level i need to almost
forget the movie to watch it again
really i need to re-watch it i need to
be surprised i like mad max fury road
better
than wait that's the original one
no fury road's the newest one right it's
really good that's a new different deck
uh errors though
fair roads like 2015 oh yeah
oh well yeah i'm talking about that
decade 2000 to 2010. you like that more
than inception but it's an intense movie
yeah it's a great movie yeah it's just
that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] anxiety there
was anxiety could be in the movie that
was that that was [ __ ] caffeine and
anxiety just a rare bird too like not
everyone's gonna have the guts to make a
movie like that no way what is it about
the movie if you watch it like right
after like that it doesn't feel good or
like
i can't watch it again because i already
know everything that's going to happen
so you're good at retaining info that
you you'll remember nope i forget like
joe thinks he remembers but he doesn't i
don't remember [ __ ]
a lot of the movies so here's the funny
part right
bart didn't watch a lot of movies i
actually did watch all the same movies
you guys did i don't remember any of
them
so in essence we're kind of the same
because for me i think when i watch
re-watch it maybe because you're plot
driven so once you know what's gonna
happen right you're like it maybe ruins
the the the novelty or the surprise yeah
for me the second time around i get to
pick because there's so many details
right from like from props to the
lighting to whatever there's a lot of
foreshadowing that happens right so for
me when i watch it because i know it's
gonna happen now i'm like oh [ __ ] they
planted the seed in act one or they
planted a seed here how come i didn't
see it like fight club yeah i'm like
holy [ __ ] that's great so the second or
third time i actually enjoyed even more
because i got to see like the easter
eggs which inception does a really good
job yeah specifically i wish i could
have met that board that bar had so much
time therefore that bart didn't have a
schedule for watching inception and then
i'll also after he's like no i can't i
got it but he has time to watch
spider-man five times and then ten times
ten kinds of spider-man it's a perfect
uh segway so a a florida man sets a
record a world record for watching
spider-man no way home the new
spider-man movie over 300 times i've
been teaching
i bet i bet you [ __ ] i probably beat
this for you
yeah you think so so like
[ __ ] i don't even know why he plays
at night we always uh before we go to
sleep i always watch about 20-30 minutes
of a movie right i go hey taika what do
you want to watch tonight um
spider-man no way home how can you guys
think about spider-man you know it's
gonna be spider-man no i'm like
[ __ ] just say it yeah cause
sometimes he'll go um
i spider-man no way home i'm like oh
he's trying to [ __ ] with me i'm like
i'ma just put her on dude trying to show
you his library of intelligence
wait five seconds
can you even watch it at home
yeah
that's how this florida man was able to
watch it at home over 300 oh
i thought he went to the brand that's
the thing it's not it's brand [ __ ]
new good but i don't know about [ __ ]
300 times as an adult yeah but do you
think tiger's watched it like even 50
times like what do you think what do you
think you're at
he has select scenes his favorite scenes
probably like a thousand times his
favorite scenes a thousand so he loves
it when did all of you guys watch it
someone spoke yeah i watched it you
didn't see it no i don't care he knows
the spoilers okay so the favorite part
is when all three spider-man show up now
so he's really excited about that
um he likes it when there's a sand guy
where he's [ __ ] his hands are leaking
[ __ ]
he likes that guy i like that part at
all yeah he like i like he's like when
he's leaking sand
her hands that's one way to put it i
guess we can all kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] sand stan
uh who likes that those are like his
these main scenes he wants to fast
forward to so he wants to fast first
just the sand can you fat can you do
that can i get the sand guy again yeah
well i remember being a kid and my
parents talk about this all the time but
i also remember too watching
ghostbusters and my parents like
recorded it because like the movie came
up before i was live but then you know
like 1980 [ __ ] eight or something i'm
watching it i'm a couple years old right
i'm like four
and um i i would watch the part where
they all get dressed up and they're all
going to like go to the first place for
the first time and so my my mom and dad
were like you watched that like a
[ __ ] 100 times a day and so i was
like hit rewind on the vcr and i knew
how to hit play just when they're
gearing up together
i watched the whole movie a bunch but i
would keep on watching that part when
they get ready that's tight why i just
because i love return of the dragon
bruce lee
i used to watch that movie [ __ ] every
day to the point where i would wear the
same [ __ ] he would wear i wear the
[ __ ] wife beater yeah and then like
the navy blue like sweatpants that's the
best that when you dress up like
and i'd always be like you want some
chinese spare ribs i'd always do that
part and then you turned into a fighter
yeah i used to watch that [ __ ] all the
time so you don't even re-watch action
movies for the choreography i watched uh
michael jackson moonwalker
multiple times as a kid
that's just long too the real it's not
even really a movie no it's not a movie
it's not that long
moonwalker nah i don't think that [ __ ]
was like
the disney ride no the the the complete
moonwalker movie with joe pesci yeah oh
that like an hour has it's like a movie
like thing yeah maybe i thought it was
40 minutes because it has all the music
videos in it plus the the narrative it's
sick man did you watch captain eel like
non-stop hell yeah but but this guy goes
out a lot of maintenance yeah yeah and
then you don't even [ __ ] go on rides
you just watch captain eel all day i
went on the ride i loved captain yale
dude you know the [ __ ] little
wannabe-ass star wars creatures that
came out
i was tired they were done by that thing
by the stan winston
star wars guys yeah what about finding
neverland how many times you watch that
wow i watched it and i was like man look
at these lions son of a [ __ ]
also in the divix area where people were
bootlegging movies and putting on cds
and stuff like that lord of the rings
the fellowship of the ring i remember i
got like a burned copy of that
and
on the second cd because it took
multiple cds on the second cd i would
re-watch the last fight over and over i
used to watch that a lot too okay where
you know aragorn is like where is the
ring and then they start fighting all
the urukai whatever is nerdy [ __ ] and
the matrix came out on dvd and i had a
dvd player matrix was crazy
the lobby scene i must have watched it
oh my god oh that scene i played
yeah he's like a metal detector sorry
remove all jewelry all kinds of certain
[ __ ] he's like holy [ __ ]
and he just blasts them [ __ ] blows
that's how it ends i like when it ends
the elevator closes and the slab of
marble falls out yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right that's a completely
different beast because there was
nothing like that yeah yeah
nothing nothing in the way
moved and the way that like it was all
clear not like like vhs was or
the titanic vhs you were wanting to just
watch the boobies
i did that like a thousand times yeah i
was fired
have you ever watched the titanic now
though and you see the cg and you're
like
the [ __ ]
it looks like a fake boat it's in 64.
on titanic
this [ __ ] is sick man this [ __ ]
big-ass queen mary looking thing oh yeah
when you see the making of for the first
time you have way more respect for that
movie
do you remember being at the theater
though and seeing the [ __ ] vote
you're like damn i never saw in theater
i didn't see it in theater either
[ __ ] cool i saw it with my mom my
cousin took me and when the booby scene
came on they were just like
uh
we didn't know that was gonna i don't
know i'm not gonna tell them i got my
first boner in that scene dude do you
guys remember the first movie you've
ever watched in the movie theater i
think it was titanic batman 1989. mine
was batman you were allowed to see that
yeah that was the gritty one wasn't it
for me um since i grew up not being able
to watch me movies or tv shows really uh
my mom dropped me off at one of her
friend's house because i had like a no
school day or something and then that
mom took me and her son who was like
five years older to go watch a movie for
the first time and it was ace ventura
and that was the one where he was like
spying through i think like the rhino
[ __ ] away yeah
climbing out i remember so good dying of
laughter so hard i think i had like a
seizure and my
stomach
wow my first paradise was return of the
jedi which is a star wars movie but but
i was so young i don't remember it but
that's what my parents say was my first
movie but then 1989 batman i remember
actually watching in theaters and then i
remember afterwards my parents took me
to a costume store at the mall where we
went to see the movie and i put on a
batman cape which is like the shitty
little cape it's like [ __ ] costume
store 20 k but it had like little batman
years and [ __ ] i remember looking myself
in the mirror and going like i am
[ __ ] batman that's crazy i loved that
costume and cape was one of the best
[ __ ] things to do yeah just turns you
into a super hero immediately you're
like i am literally batman this is
insane
how am i batman
but i remember looking at myself seeing
that because i just watched the movie
it's no different it's no
different
grown man yeah and you're just like what
the [ __ ] kate doesn't even cover my
t-shirt
i'm literally the [ __ ] batman what
the [ __ ] my parents were killed i have
to get revenge
like it's crazy with the mind of a job
crazy
it's so configured to be an auto
make-believe like you don't got to like
try well and your dad's calling you
batman too so you're like i am uh kind
of killing this baby
i'm like hey dad the mask is down it's
bruce please thank you
one of the things i asked uh we're doing
thai guys like homework whatever and one
of them was like what's one of your
wishes and then he goes to be bit by a
spider